les belges je vais t'aimer rabattement
ginette peu pied au festival rite halal
il peut pas parler comme tout le monde
il faut qu'ils chantent bâtiment avait
dit le romantisme tu m'avais dit
romantique tu m as du magnifique ce
phénomène
ouais mais moi le romantisme c'est pas
comme ça que je le vois mal quand je
vais au bal tu comprends rien mais qui
me dit tu prends une bière en finit dans
la voiture bon moi il remonte il s'est
tu veux une bière on vit dans la voiture
s'il te plaît
moi ça va faire ses chansons tu m'as dit
à l'ats bal des pompiers thème à dire à
faire la chanson fais des chansons pour
moi j'en écris je n'ai qu'une rage il
est pompier
tu vas la plus belle quand je m'approche
de tes seins je ramasse plus avec le net
avec une paire l'instant pas j'en prends
plein les oreilles tu m'aimes pas la
chanson non pas que tu vois que ça rien
si je promets rien que pour toi jamais
fait ça touchant mais celui-là je t'ai
dit rien on sait rien c'est la chanson
s'appelle arrière mais sait-on des
restaurants avant quand j'ai chanté les
gens je disais qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je chante disait rien alors mais moi
j'ai fait une chanson qui s'appelle rien
même quand ils veulent rien j'ai rien
n'étant pas du romantisme on me molin
parce que là on sait pas tenir moi ce
que je veux et ses 7 ans vincent scooter
toi ce coton ouais je veux que tu sois
mon mal gauthier comprends je vais te
chanter mais commençait déjà elle est
jolie elle est charmante
non les jolies je vais l'aimer ginette
dupuis ginette de plus une note publiée
la plus belle du quartier la plus belle
d'aubervilliers
les journées les chansons à sacre en
menant les deux mois les paroles et la
musique s'est inscrite à tapas
l'original et quand j'en mets toi c'est
toi qui es tu va réveiller mon vieux
déjà qui le rend très bon roi hier soir
en plus il s'est acheté un fusil à pompe
les incitants pour un coup dans les
fesses je vais dire un coup de pub tient
en effet ça fait mal moi ça que j'avais
c'est regarder ton corps bouger ginette
du pied ce que je veux c'est aimer
passer ma vie à te le garder ginette du
pied je veux regarder
ouais mais tu vas me regarder un moment
puis tu vas chanter choper atlantique
eut livré si je mens près de dix ans tu
connais qu'est ce que c'est une nouvelle
pâte
c'est ça ouais des parts débattent mais
torticolis
non seulement y chante mal en pis si les
cons non merci mais moi ce que ça va
sauter mais j'aime les mecs n'ont pas
encore dit si tu poses cinq minutes de
dans la rue des glacis désaccord moi ce
que je veux c'est aimer je veux
t'épouser je veux t'épouser gym pompiers
via le jeu termes humains du 9e art and
you les mondes on arrive à dieu c'est
pas ça non je veux t'épouser non
pourquoi non parce que mon mari veut pas
qu'est ce que je fais eh ben tu disais
merde ça fait rien j'ai flotté ma
guitare sous les fenêtres de josette
chanteur
les idées des prix les spécialités je
suis tentée par quelques secondes pour
parfaire mon biquet l'a jamais mangé
bien sa maman german n'assister paul vi
que ça ne m'intéresse pas au relais moi
je viens je me promène je fais du lèche
vitrine elle c'est gentil ça mais c'est
pas drôle tout simplement je suis pas
pour rigoler mais vraiment vous tient
pour faire pénitence
non seulement on m'avait dit que ça
existait mais je voulais me rendre
compte par moi même atari ans et c'est
plus marrante par correspondance toute
cette misère sexuelle
c'est cet effrayant un vrai compte tous
ces gens qui rôdent la langue pendante
en bavant de concupiscence coeur insérer
des passages way to say cette chaussée
pitcho c'est l'artt corps
j'aimerais que monsieur visiter le
captiva faut un
en plus je suis sûr que ça vaut la peau
des fesses non ça n'est pas en quoi les
petits jouent on doit oser croll avait
pauvres gens et le petit jeu ça va
chercher dans les combien l'info quand
tu es à les deux sens oui et non c'est
ce qu'on va voir ses proies que vayrac
et la poule est il grand jeu ça va
aubin c'est le double a forcément
olalalala est alors pour ceux qui
viennent plusieurs fois par semaine ça
monte un oui je sais pas où vous faites
des abonnements des tarifs dégressifs
des facilités de paiement
non mes placards et oui en liquide
l'envers me vous rendez compte
alors quelqu'un je prends moi quelqu'un
qui vient admettons le bon une moyenne
de 5,6 fois par semaine on est content
quand ça lui fait c'est lui non mais non
cette affaire va les mater caisse
enregistreuse non tu prends trois pour
une grande surface et moi pour une boîte
de cassoulet là
ben quoi je suis un consommateur
responsable moi madame je m'occupe de
vérifier leur apporter lité prix ouais
tu cherches un homme d'excès ou quoi non
mais dis donc j'ai jamais une
réclamation a study by alors vous êtes
tu vois tes 2 que se donne une facture
avec la tva mans bah quoi vous êtes un
petit commerce avec l'union sur rue une
pme
oui parce que moi j'en fais travail du
monde bien à commencer par les
cordonniers et avec tout ce que je
balance à de l'or là alors vous êtes
taxé comme un produit de luxe ou
produits de première nécessité première
nécessité je suis d'utilité publique -
messieurs comme la croix-rouge tien vaut
faire nationalisée enfin merci bien pour
me retrouver au chômage technique
bouteille du moment qu'on casse pas
votre outil de travail
simone il en coûte assez cher en
entretien
enfin là dans l'eau vous arriver à
équilibrer votre balance des paiements
ça y est autant qui rend d'autant qu'ils
n'ont même pas ce que vous prônez vous
avez vous avez un joli capital
joli petit fond de commerce
en faudrait pas gâcher faut investir
mais je demande que ça moi n'investit
non investir dans la pierre les studios
les garages les boks ah oui tiens ça me
rappelle mes débuts
enfin ça évidemment pour ça faut
quelqu'un qui s'y connaît ce coin
remarquer moi j'ai bien réussi à assurer
mes arrières
ah ouais mais tu voudras est équipé des
mines je demanderai pas mieux je
pourrais gérer votre portefeuille comme
ça vous auriez les mains libres pour
jouir de vos ressources
puis je vous ferai jouer en bourse ça me
coûterait combien tout ça ah ben ça
évidemment au départ la mise de fonds
faut compter 50 % de vos gains quoi webb
a vivoté adulte doit ranger une pitié
pour autant oui seulement moi je vous
fais faire la culbute mais bien leurs
fonds voire dix panneaux ouais bah c'est
une affaire qu'on pourrait essayer de
conclure assez rapidement n'aboutirait
d'anti the way seulement il ya une chose
moi avant de me lancer j'aimerais quand
même bien savoir si l'affairé scène eva
joly va à six mois et voilà ça va me
coûter un rond
à la différence de l'animal l'homme lui
est humain et c'est ce caractère
d'humanité que nous allons explorer
aujourd'hui autour d'un spécimen
d'humanoïdes particulier l'homme du 20e
siècle
comme vous pouvez le constater l'homme
du xxème siècle n'est ni plus ni moins
bon que celui des siècles précédents
ainsi notre ami coco puisqu'il s'appelle
coco dit bonjour coco bonjour coco non
bonjour bonjour
notre ami coco donc et sans doute moins
bon que romeo mais plus beaux nettement
que quasimodo intérêts dans l'ensemble
la morphologie générale est la même
qu'avant à ceci près cependant qu'au
xxème siècle certains hommes comme du
reste leur ami concours portent des
semelles orthopédiques ce que l'on ne
voyait jamais au moyen-âge par exemple
c'est grâce à cette jupe au fait mon
service
de même la forme du crâne n'a pas
beaucoup changé au cours des siècles des
mois et même des années
elle est toujours ovoïde oblongue robe
du soir
tu peux mettre la main j'ai pour les
cheveux gras le front est toujours placé
en haut du visage au dessus du nez à la
base du cuir chevelu le nez toujours au
milieu de la face même si les tordus
comme c'est le cas ici
tordu toi même et la bouche toujours en
bas au dessus du coup et oui les filles
c'est pas demain que servir de modèle et
picasso en fait ce qui caractérise
réellement sur le plan physique l'homme
du 20e siècle
c'est le port de la barbe vous devez y
aller c'est une vraie la barbe à notre
époque en effet présente deux avantages
d'abord elle permet de se dissimuler
quand on a commis une villa d'action je
vous jure c'est pour vous
et elle est un véritable garde-manger
alors quand on a un petit creux à 4
heures je dois bien avoir de jaune
d'oeuf de midi à mettre sous la dent en
ce qui concerne le niveau intellectuel
de l'homme du 20e siècle
aucun doute celui ci est beaucoup plus
malin qu'autrefois beaucoup plus apte à
défendre ses propres intérêts mieux
armés pour affronter la vie c'est pour
moi qu aurait construit une cathédrale
avec un salaire en dessous du smic
un jour de congé par semaine et pas de
vacances au mois d'aout dès qu'il se
sent interpellé par une question d'ordre
international l'homme du xxème siècle se
montre très inventif j'ai buté deux
vieux j'ai pété les lunettes à 2 minutes
dans les files d'attentes
j'ai foutu dit à la chaîne affirme je
suis passé devant tout le monde est
totale je lisais
mais place pour barcelone munich on
parle des princes la culture est une des
préoccupations majeures de l'homme du
20e siècle
je regarde le grand échiquier tous les
mois depuis 10 ans j'ai toujours tout
bon jeu des mille francs je paye toutes
mes mensualités pour être abonné pour
recevoir mise en cycle [ __ ] universel et
en plus j'ai un abonnement historia
alors qu'on vienne pas m'emmerder en
disant que je suis pour un homme
responsable en ce qui concerne le sexe
c'est à une véritable émancipation une
libération totale de l'individu et de
ses pulsions de ses pulsions les plus
hautes que nous assistons en cette fin
de xxème siècle bon ma feignasses de
femmes en train de faire la vaisselle
je vais aller aux [ __ ] c'est ça c'est
samedi j'ai touché la paye
sur le plan politique dans certains pays
comme le nôtre le 20e siècle a permis à
l'homme de choisir librement le
gouvernement qu'il désirait et ce dans
le strict respect de la liberté d'autrui
premièrement je fais pas de politique
deuxièmement mes opinions politiques ça
regarde que moi
troisièmement ce qui est pas d'accord
avec moi je lui casse la tête 4e manche
dit jamais pour qui je veux avant et
après je dis que j'ai voté pour ce cas
gagner cinquièmement ce mois-ci ya la
guerre je m'en fous à mon âge seraient
plus mobilisés et encore d'occupation
faut pas dramatiser sur na de
l'éducation peut très bien s'en tirer
mais si révolutionnaire que soit vous
êtes le voir les moeurs de l'homme
moderne
nous remarquerons qu'il reste toujours
attaché à l'une des valeurs
fondamentales de notre civilisation
la cellule familiale bon maman mais à
son club de majorettes
ma femme est à l' usine mes vieux sont l
hospice avec d'autres vieux donc ils
s'ennuient pas eh ben je suis peinard je
vous quitte je vais boire un coup au
bistrot
huit jours
les huit jours qui m'ont mis en
recrutement des filles pas vu la queue
du c'est bien ici le bureau de
recrutement des filles oui on l'a eu
c'est ainsi que le recrutement des
filles
oui au moins deux hommes changer de
playboy
aujourd'hui l'agent sur l'inspecteur bon
y'a du boulot hein
alors tout d'abord fera pour la
reconnaître les gones 1 alors moi je
suis pas en inspecteur je suis pas
embrigader je suis à aa alcooliques
bon je suis un homme a abrité bon y'a du
boulot
je suis à du daim voilà et pour
reconnaître les grades c'est très facile
plus nez rouge plus grande est élevé
l'adjudant gérard carrier se fait d'un
carrier études un carrier ya du boulot
on a mis des siècles à faire entrer les
filles à l'armée c'est pourquoi il faut
que moore 1 alors d'abord j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi voulait rentrer alors
moi avant j'étais bonne à tout faire
oui je me suis rendu compte que j'étais
bonne à rien alors à force je me suis
dit bon pas ma fille
le xiii plus qu'une chose c'est l'armée
et puis je me suis ce sera un travail
quoi voilà si vous cherchez du travail à
l'armée il ya erreur parce que nous
aussi nous sommes touchés par la crise
depuis la guerre d'algérie au chômage
n'a rien foutu on travaille un petit peu
en intérim que le tchad un coup le liban
mais c'est pas ça on travaille c'est pas
une bonne motivation et ben j'en ai une
autre c'est chez moi c'est un peu
hérédité envoyer ses pères en fils parce
que mon père était dans la milice oui ça
ça ira
bon moi c'est à cause d'un chagrin
d'amour
ah bon ça se voit points-là ne serait-ce
que ça s'est passé il ya trois ans il a
dépassé alors eh ben voilà c'est que
j'ai quitté mon mari pour mon amour j'ai
vécu avec moi l'allemand très très
heureuse pendant trois normales en cause
et puis je suis pas ce qui s'est passé
hier soir tout d'un coup ça m'a pris
jamais devenu un chagrin d'amour a dit
dans as
alors j'ai décidé de rentrer dans les
ordres mais c'était complet
oui je sais pas ce qu'il se passe mais
je peux vous dire qu'ils se bousculent
au goupillon il paraît que les gens des
problèmes de foie en ce moment à passer
sur le ciment voulait pas landreau non
parce que justement
du boulot ça voulait dire exactement
contraire pour apprendre les quads bon
et puis d'abord savoir dans quelle arme
vous voulez servir ça c'est un peu moi
enfin on m'a parlé d'un engin qui tire
1500 cola minutes
super j'aimerais bien le voir parce que
au début j'avais pensé aller dans génie
mais faire la lessive tous les jours ce
matin et sport ya du boulot
alors ça vous le dire un instrument qui
tient 1500 coup les murs et une
mitraillette un top spin 1 d'abord ce
geste vous savez ce que ça qui mitraille
à dos une petite mitre bon meet my est
mitraillée nique une moitié de triet
il ya du boulot un bon bout dans quelles
armes ou les servir des larmes je
voudrais aller oui donc là on voulait
aller faut y aller dedans
bah oui mais dans un temps canon d'un
pistolet j'aurais pas beaucoup de pleurs
et puis c'est moins confortable le du
boulot bon d'abord si vous savez les
lions ont été rappelés pour l'école
d'officiers légion sur la deux
bah si c'est pour faire la chaîne on va
merci et vous voyez maintenant vous nous
voyez chanter tiens voilà du boudin ya
du boulot parce que l'uniforme ça se
fait pas comme ça l'uniforme ça se
mérite
ne serait ce que pour les avantages
qu'ils procurent pourquoi par exemple
comme avantage
demi-tarif dans le métro au cinéma dans
les trains et puis si vous avez la
chance d'être invalide vous avez une
place entière dans le métro et bien sûr
un truc mais ça ça vous concerne très
peu c'est pour draguer quoi c'est mieux
mais ça c'est pas à ce propos dragueuse
domine ça vous irait si les mines sont
pas insensibles
alors là y'a aucun risque où les
fleurets vous sautent dessus
eh ben ça me changera de roger 1
un titre comme un sablier les dragueurs
de mines à 8,1 à s'habiller quand le
monde ranger trier mais l'iran tierces à
talon aiguille les pancartes et le kaki
voyons et puis les bandes molletières
réveille aussi du boulot dit à l'heure
mais alors on peut mourir ça oui ça il
ya des gens très salée aux paroles le
baroud
vous aimez sympa et ça me plaît le monde
il est beau tout de suite pour cette
rentrée il a les fesses comme un jardin
sont les cinquante et un nul le savez
que c'est fait pour ça alors et alors
moi moi je fais de la première seule
date inconnue a fait mon ton beau avec
son entendu mon nom en gros comme ça
ouais ouais c'est ça qui serait une
victoire du féminisme iran fin des
monuments morte
ouais bon boulot
pour faire un sketch comique il faut
d'abord des interprètes comique
regardez cet homme il n'est pas comique
il ne fera jamais rires donc à disent
même qu'ils feraient mieux d'arrêter le
métier je travaille correctement je
voudrais bien nourrir tous en revanche
voici maintenant un véritable individus
comique une nature drôle
irrésistiblement
comment as tu du poil
maintenant que nous avons les comédiens
il nous faut les idées on nous dit
souvent le voyant dans la rue mais
comment faites vous pour trouver autant
d'idées où allez vous chercher tout ça
etc
mais dans la vie de tous les jours tout
simplement écouter cette conversation au
journal beurre bonjour robert tu vas
bien maintenant je me suis déchiré ma
veste
alors c'est pas de veine et puis je me
suis fait deux trous aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe j'espère que ma mère à pouvoir mais
recoudre d'un mois aussi les dents ouais
acheter un nouveau costume pour
remplacer oui oui pas de couleur oh bah
c'est bien allez salut salut albert vous
avez vu plutôt plein sinistre même
regarder ce que nos forces a dû rire nos
galériens de la bonne humeur vont
réussir à en faire allez-y les gars
bonjour lise ses épaules vous avez vu un
gaz hilarant dans les cinq premières
secondes
c'est ça l'efficacité maintenant
regardons toutes les ressources que peut
nous apporter le calembour
on jouera d'ailleurs savoir albert
bonjour lisent ça va l'isq
je n'ai pas les épaules aux bas rhinois
pon tu vas bien dont je me suis déchiré
ma reste au met à l'heure tu t'es fait
un accroc paul
vous avez vu la différence
trois gags trois gags dans les 30
premières secondes du sketch c'est ça
l'efficacité bouvard bravo les gars nous
sommes là aussi pour toujours dans la
bonne humeur et la joyeuseté instruire
le public
les ducs et lui élever son niveau
culturel
c'est normal regardez ce que par
conséquent nous sommes capables de faire
toujours dans ce but allait il dit moi
apple tu t'es acheté un nouveau
restaurant à deux couleurs bonbon
lesquels rouge et noir rouge et noir
mais c'est un scandale
voilà le type même de l'exxon glide
culturel cette fameuse interjections et
la caricature bien connue d'une des
expressions favorites d'un homme
politique
mais c'est aussi vous voulez vous en
êtes rendu compte
une allusion au merveilleux livre de
stendhal le rouge et le noir et ça vous
le saviez évidemment les références
culturelles ne sont pas toujours
compréhensible par tous aussi les grands
professionnels du comique comme c'est le
cas chez philippe bouvard on recoupe
souvent à des accessoires de vrais
professionnels
alice illégaux didon paul tu t'es acheté
un nouveau casting il ya des toiles
américaine rouge et noir rouge et noir
mais c'est un scandale
vous avez vu la différence vous avez été
tout de suite beaucoup plus l'ombre d'un
rire mais oui bien sûr nous pouvons les
applaudir
cette grande leçon d'efficacité un seul
conseil à vous donner à vos crayons fait
sens au temps et à bientôt
si je t'assure vraiment sûr qu'on sent
pas encore les normes et non plus
prendre vis a fait la course prend bien
garde la leur ce à l'assemblée c'est la
wii le pic de diot au la réduit des
trépassés la ceyrac de la mort est là
juste derrière toi un élan boat
d'anoraks du belge qui a fait la course
en solo la semaine dernière aux appuis
dont il ya des edelweiss
quoi essien vraiment oui vraiment facile
qui posera maintenant est pas maintenant
ce n'est pas le moment à bompas
refroidir faut en profiter tant qu'on
allait muscle soe bande et il me
rappelle ma femme mais elle est où là
c'est beau poule à 1
ces mots c'est ça qu'on voit c'est
violer les grands espaces tate n'a
jamais eu d'ennuis que la police lui
binaire non je disais ça pour détendre
l'atmosphère un bon réseau qu'est ce que
t'as qu'est ce que c'est pas de jets les
miquettes mais on dirait qu'il ya le
brouillard qui descend et alors qu'est
ce que ça fait vraiment à temps j'en
pensais ce défi salle dumont grand
insulaire oui dans la vallée on a dit
qu'on ce sommet à 4 heures il est quand
même 19h45 et halo 1 qui la faute aux
symboles pied sur très potes ne pas
pouvoir être à l'eau ya leur y ait des
télés car en bon chiner cher pas à
déchets repris nécessaire pas pressée
que je cherchais choix de serre toi à
bout de mes bons desserts pas y dans
l'himalaya et c'est toujours le
tiers-monde cas la meilleure boire
moi je bouge plus rémois plus jeune
fille jeanne et si jamais le brouillard
givrant et à lomé excès se transforme au
blizzard
ah non vous avez des blizzards d'en
juger q comment comment qu'on fait après
mais l'aura pas crever la maison
on a on a des miroirs réflecteurs alors
on envoie des messages dans le soleil un
coucou un coup l'eau un coucours bonjour
la colonne de secours
il est 7h45 et à la belle série
événement depuis longtemps mais est à
l'eau est alors avoir une petite noix
oui sur laquelle vient marquer plus est
d'être oeuvres d'art
ouais bon et battus nous mais quand on
voit la fusée dans 10minutes bonjour
l'hélicoptère s'est plaint d'une arrière
mon gamin encore
là tu peux lire je suis franchement
dépouillé de rien venir et non seulement
aux coups de fils ni aux joues avec ton
sec avec nos vies maintien comme ça la
future à la non vraiment on va trouver
ici sans secours est mort et nous sa
part des fonds mais non tout ça monsieur
ta ta ta voulu frapper cette montagne
elle est trop tôt pour prévoir et nous
sommes est planté un drapeau l'eco
artisan comme un cadre est plus concret
jobs n'est pas plus concrète pili même
bateau pour la houle
regardons ça c'est pysyk et leurs
descendants
non tu sais quoi est-ce qu'on peut s'y
est fait oui on va essayer de joie de
leur refus les refuges oui ça jamais
jamais le directeur du refuge y ait
peiné comme un phoque annelé boutaher
ans et demi tour mais non ya là mais on
va attendre la colonne de secours
il y aura sûrement des saint-bernard
avec du rhum autour du rock et laura
quoi manger quoi boire du café chaud et
ça a été un buffet montagnards gratuit
j'ai une idée en attendant les secours
tout est bon et on va serrer oui l'un
contre l'autre pour avoir dit ce haut
lieu uniquement pour avoir chaud la wii
uniquement pour avoir son bien sûr mais
dans le fond tu avais peut-être raison
après tout oui on aurait peut-être dû
aller dans l'himalaya henry l'himalaya
oh là là parce que l'himalaya un
accident vous arrive au plat tout le
monde est au courant bien fait on en
serait resté bloqué en eau qu on a été
obligé de manger un sherpa vont suivre
et puis après ça on aurait fait un film
sur nous on aurait fait confiance du
monde plaisir et on aurait pu faire du
pognon la dernière minute pour li li
kaunas de ski les anoraks ni du v12 un
ruisseau à sa femme trognon alors que la
10 minute mort ou vif
fr3 grenoble
quelle connerie l'alpinisme
oh oh oh oh ça fait du bien quand ça
s'arrête
didon j'en ai plein les oreilles
je suis complètement abrutis moi je vais
devenir sur wii à ses voisins du dessus
la force de passer l'aspirateur à
n'importe quelle heure y'en a marre au
lycée hebinger drôlement bien aimé le
moment où tu m'a touché c'est à dire que
bon ça faisait trois heures qu'on
discute et qu'on se regarde est alors
j'ai passé avec oui mais m'a étonné as
tu m'a drôlement surprise parce que je
pensais pas que tout temps les vrais ton
pyjama ça tu as fait quelque chose
ah bah oui parce que j'avais pas pts et
est tatoué
on remarque ce point vrai tatouage c'est
un dessin que j'ai fait moi-même à
l'antre avec mon stylo plume pour
t'exciter remaniement pour accepter at
s'excite drôlement bien sexy gala
curiosité parce qu'on se demande ce que
c'est en substrat c'est un symbole qui
relance des pulsions indépendamment de
ton toit au niveau ton désir sur mon âge
tu croiras ben addi dont moi je voulais
savoir aussi quelque chose j'aurais
voulu savoir si tu préférais quand
j'étais dessus ou quand j'étais dessous
à bon bah bah moi si tu veux pas parce
que si tu veux bon toute façon quand il
y en a un au dessus l'autre et dessous
et inversement mais pour dormir c'est
mieux sur le côté tu sais moi j'ai lu
dans un livre dans un manuel que il ya
des gens avait il sa part à bah oui bah
c'est normal si tu fais une fois que tu
as vu l'autre tenu bon bah tu t'attaches
à lui ah mais non mais non mais non mais
il s'attache esata et solidaire
ah bon c'est pourquoi tombés de leur lit
en tout cas j'ai adoré quand tu m'a
prise tout à l'heure à quel moment
pendant le dîner avec ta mère a les
photos sont bien réussis ça va être
chouette mais c'est bien toute façon les
préliminaires c'est important tout ce
qu'on fait avant si on s'amuse bien sûr
passer une bonne soirée tout ça oui si
on fait du sport avant comme l'autre
soir après souper
quand j'ai eu l'idée qu'on aille courir
20 km dans la forêt de fontainebleau bas
après on a bien être à demain bien on a
bien dormi ouais tu vois c'que important
si c'est les aphrodisiaques
moi j'aime bien quand tu nous prépares
de du boudin antillais la purée de
piments rouges
et qu'on mange avec des grandes karting
de moutarde et en dessert chacun une
bonne livre de gingembre confit au
poivre vert
et puis en plus avec tous avaient une
bonne colle et de vinaigre là dessus
pour faire descendre le tout allait bien
remarqué aussi des aphrodisiaques
qu'exit la vue et ouais et photos ça on
devrait tapisser la chambre de photos
oui on devra remettre des photos comme
les photos qu'on a vu tu sais l'autre
jour au sex shop là tu sais et les trucs
là avec différents modèles tout ça pour
en mettre des photos comme ça les photos
par exemple avec des hommes avec des
femmes avec des animaux y avait des
animaux s'ils en veulent et c'est pas la
peine puisque on a déjà au mur le
canevas nous à faire ta mère ça présente
des chevaux à perdre
oui j'oubliais aussi algorithmes sur le
calendrier des postes ah bah oui tu vois
il doit envoyer une position j'ai bien
aimer l'autre soir je m'étais coincé la
tête dans le tiroir de la table de nuit
et j'avais les pieds sur la poignée de
la porte de chambre
ah ouais mais je m'en souviens pas de
celle là moins abondante et épaules
c'est à moi tu sais j'ai un truc que
j'adore ça ça fait complètement
complètement frémir c'est quand tu
prends ton élan du dessus de l'armoire
loges le jeu mais bon on coule alors la
saq fois leur sac fois c'est bon alors à
chaque fois tu t'es l'a signé j'en ai
marre j'en ai même deux et de une fois
et oui voilà la vie dont moi ce que
j'allais encore plus alors là c'est
quand tu parles pendant la cheville
quand je te quand je te dis que j'aime
des pieds alors et puis c'est drôlement
bien chez nous au niveau du couple c'est
que on a fait le tour du sexe ah oui ça
on en a bien fait le tour fera 10 dons
et puis par exemple toujours plus sur sa
chance et chaque fois on maîtrise la
chose d fera mouche et puis on l'a
réinventons réinvente chauffe sévère
on a vu une couverture rouge sur le
débat aujourd'hui une grégy communs et
d'accords haut placés pour les idées
qu'ils demandent et la table de nuit
la top de nuit demain va vendre à neutre
et après demain
et bien moi ce que je sais faire c'est
mettre le son staff au surlendemain le
chien ne regarde
et pour le week-end on mettra sa tenue
de cuir aux canaries peut plaire
vous connais un peu maintenant et j'ai
senti votre appréhension au départ rien
qu'à l'énoncé du sujet vous êtes
rassurés oui sur assurément ça a été
d'une grande pudeur
oui oui oui vous savez qui a dit il
avait placé sa main là où il n'ya rien
chez elle et elle avait placé la sienne
là où ce n'était pas tout à fait de même
chez lui
quelle idée de dos et non jean fataliste
il ya toute une littérature érotique
l'intérêt que vous connaissez
admirablement oui vaut aussi apollinaire
diderot etc
r je crois que tous les grands les
grands auteurs se sont même amusés à se
mettre un peu d'air dans le chemin de
l'humour à partir de de l'eros mouais
bon eh bien je vous invite à revenir
demain ce sera demain le dernier jour de
la promotion francis huster ce sera le
bouquet la bonne à papa et moi on a
parlé de tout sauf moins pour une fois
on en parlera demain
allez les bleus allez les bleus allez
affronter projet allait mieux aller
lourdes où il va je suis là à dimanche
pour me dire c'est moral de tomber trop
lourd il est un peu lourd dragon bouton
emmenez moi j'allais maison il reste le
procès d'intention
je suis son bla remarque les gens
tellement marqué si la confiance ne sera
pas plus à plus à l'est mais nous
courent pas la bouche ouverte pour ça
qu'on a semé mais pourquoi vous montre
déjà perdu à la semaine dernière à
l'apartheid on avait lui même la crainte
et moi je suis pas venu ici ce soir
ah non ça s'appelle dort pas tout seul
sinon tu vas t'on rugby alors sa saison
très fine si tu loupes les biens qui
comprend plus rien fait sur et moi je
préfère regarder le film que la libye se
tient dimanche par semaine valero enfin
moi je dimanche mais l'argent l'étiage
jusque là jusque là alors le dimanche
matin la messe l'après midi de football
et puis soir mais bigoudis et bouger
plus vite symbole à dimanche après midi
parce qu'on vient de me coltiner ma
belle mère elle est rouge pas possible
les fleurs aux gosses
la caisse a acheté à nouveau dans typhon
livré que le bas alors quand je pense en
face des gens comme toi des toubabs une
fois tu m'as permis à foison pas aller à
savent très bien qu'ils perdent les
bourrelets par la phase 1 on m'a parlé
pour les ça tient chaud l'hiver c'est
pas ton maigrichon bois mon maigrichonne
c'est moi qui leur est chaud et humide
même mais n'y fait je suis que du
chauffage à fond à bien une telle
affaire la pointe déjà la caisse au
supermarché le soir est un mari de la
dame et les mêmes ne regarde pas mais me
regarde pas c'est une bulle qui pour
garder le bébé n'allait pas laisser
parler d'elle c'est milla
cela dit les samedis et beaucoup de la
ressemblance ou encore du doubs les
filles du donjon c'est pas ton
maigrichon careca sécher sur un tonneau
et racontera temps poussive non mérieux
en tracteur ou six frappes ou si sa
venue ne sait pas que ça soit sur la
glace mais en tout cas ils courent plus
vite ils éternuent mais s'est consacré
dans les buts son nouveau mari oui ah
bah non marc évidemment il prévoyait
tard débute avec les jambes écartées fil
à la patte les gens doivent inventer ce
n'était pas faute d'orthographe lui est
pas mon doudou il veut pas être
cardiaque de passage où il a pris le
ballon dans le fond que sagna couper la
tige f1 pourrait faire un film à la
vente libre
merci merci cela s'appelle harper si
ceux ci réclament comme il habille
l'arbitré béninois
oui oui les herbes et islande ils ont eu
à baisser mortelle dans leur ferme et
viennent lac dimanche ils viennent là
pour se distraire un tout petit peu ils
sont courageux ses jambes je n'avais pas
bien bâlois mes condoléances à mme est
content de les entendre
la dette
non
la belle vient messieurs s'il vous plaît
vos premières questions bien d'abord
bonjour monsieur madame madame princesse
j'aurai une question
d'abord c'est pour pour jour de france
un jour elle décide d'abord on cesse
vous allez de se voir pour nom de vos
admirateurs en devenant la femme d'un
seul homme maintenant et j'aimerais
savoir si vous ne pensez pas que votre
cote de popularité risque de baisser
ok ok ce qui s'est passé ça veut dire
tout le monde qu'il me faudra s'habituer
bon vieux un petit sourire là pour la
vie du rail
merci une question du journal mon tricot
est-ce que vous avez l'attention de
tricoter vous même la layette dans votre
futur enfant
ben voyons c'est bien connu qu'on a pas
assez de fric pour s'acheter des
fringues suivant francis huster de la
vie ouvrière intense
voilà une question qui me brûle les
lèvres
que faites vous de vos journées
princesse comment sortent et monsieur on
ne répondra pas ce genre de questions
non mais on fait rien mais personne n'a
besoin de le savoir
23 santé est ce que vous pourriez
reprendre la position sortez-la pour je
suis partout je vous prie
sortez monsieur georges question la
souplesse c'est pour la vie la vie
catholique le journal du saint-père a
aussi c'est pour la vie cathodique c'est
un journal de télé j'avais menacé la vie
chaotique le journal de véhicules tout
terrain alors les groupes et vous et
c'est complet non sinon un petit sourire
s'il vous plaît la française pour le
nouvel exécuteur merci j'ai une question
pour paris match s'il vous plaît pendant
votre nuit de noce nous étions avec des
copains on était dans la chambre à côté
donc on a eu le poids des monuments bien
moi le choc des photos mais non c'est
pourquoi la rouille
alors écoutez monsieur les photos
cochonnes seront en vente après la
réunion
j'ai une question qui presse oui des
gens qui prennent ces mots c'est une
question qui les y aller badia là on va
laisser le macaroni répondre
et quoique et j'ai demandé vous ai
demandé où étaient les toilettes ou sur
les toiles étaient à côté à côté où sont
les toilettes
dans l'implant côté voilà c'est bien il
commence à savoir répondre aux
interviews dans la foulée dans la foulée
j'aimerais poser une autre question pour
le journal dans la foulée comment avez
vous fait pour séduire pauline oui
victoria alors je suis arrivé avec la
voiture la mangue et lamborghini je suis
arrivé j'avais le style je marche comme
ça quand j'ai vu pauline avec eux c'est
ce que je me suis avancé jouer comme ça
elle avait la classe les bichons et ne
jamais rester comme ça apolline apolline
il est heureux je souhaitais vous
comment voit-il points dans la ferrari
lamborghini la maserati viens on va les
manger de nos impôts comme ilan halimi a
chanté aux raviolis on est bon air 2
heures vous pourriez reprendre la foulée
pour la vie du rail la sauce faire merci
oui j'aurais une question là pour le
journal de l'almanach vermot m'a demandé
est ce que vous avez vu monte carlo mais
monsieur nous connaissons et carlo
évidemment question suivante s'il vous
plaît pour le pèlerin 20 centimes les
ânes ou là vous pourriez pas refaire les
années passées en exclusivité ça va
venir
ouais bah c'est bon merci votre sainteté
merci une question de tennis et d'eau le
seul journal qui rackettent ses lecteurs
j'aimerais savoir et on dit on prétend
c'est vrai un que vous avez fréquenté
pas mal de joueurs de tennis ne pas je
veux pas citer de noms mais par exemple
guillermo vilas john mcenroe ivan lendl
jimmy connors borotra lacoste pesci borg
noah enfin bon non non non non excusez
moi à vous n'avez pas fait conter noah
et on peut savoir pourquoi
bah écoutez j'ai un certain rang qui ne
m'autorise pas à fréquenter des gens qui
ne sont pas noble
je suis à l'aise permet toujours et je
peux dire que noah vient d'acheter une
particule il s'appelle maintenant note
de coco
vous avez la classe et vous avez la peau
alors vous avez la 306 vraiment
magnifique et est all tortellinis
une petite poche pour le trou normand
s'il vous plaît en exclusivité le
sourire
voilà c'est une question pour issy paris
s'il vous plaît pas la question est une
simple formalité parce que l'article est
sorti ce matin
alors je vais savoir bon camp lorsque
vous avez prononcé le oui fatidique
est ce que c'est vrai que vous étiez en
cloque enceinte de six mois sans voix
six mois oui moi qui sait si moi c'est
des beatles c'est moi je l'aimé un sound
moi je vais te casser la gueule qui sait
si des erreurs c'est moi et lausanne
deux mois heureusement qu'il a doublé
parce qu'ils en retiennent ces bons
apôtres
qu'est ce que je sais c'est que je dois
comprendre ne voulait pas répondre à la
question si je veux répondre à la
question je n'étais absolument pas
enceinte de six mois ni donc là moi vous
n'étiez pas enceinte
s'il n'est pas ça bon ok alors pour la
croissance et comme d'habitude on
connaissait la boîte à jouer pose une
question là de journal gouvernemental
l'humanité et combien est-ce que vous
osez dépensés par mois par rapport à
notre ère les anciens poissy pardon qui
donne malheureusement le smic
péniblement accord ce qui l'attend choix
des pneus dans un palette map
à la place d'une hlm dites moi ça un peu
lave-auto cela derrière à vous tous à
vos bijoux à vos bagues aux lots falbala
on ne répondra aux questions en français
a commenté une autre question je
voudrais vous deux je voudrais vous
demander pour quelles raisons acceptez
vous de répondre à toutes ces questions
écoutez on a tellement de choses sur le
court deux cas dominique aux vêtements
j'ai beaucoup de copains évidemment j'ai
beaucoup d'amis comme tout le monde j'ai
beaucoup je vis ma vie je m'occupe jeu à
temps
et puis on est tellement de choses
méchantes sur mon compte que j'ai voulu
remettre les choses au point et puis je
crois qu il est l'homme de ma vie donc
je vais le crier mon amour au monde
entier j'ai fait ça pose je peux poser
ma question
bon ben alors d entre copines alors
c'est pour embaucher d'autres s'en
serait douté
bon voila ma question à la hausse ça
fera du monte sur la chaîne réalise 1
j'ai une question terrible serre mais sa
voix vous me regardez quand je parle
j'aimerais savoir tels que vous voyez là
comme une grande soeur sauvage qu'est ce
que vous mettez comme dessous
tout est une question relativement
personnel mais c'est pas que je passais
à lui
en seniors je n'ai pas de dessous et eau
haulotte bien qu'il
la boucle d'oreille pour chasseurs
d'image ça marche une fois sur quatre
est embêtant merci suivant vsd moi
excusez moi j'ai pas trop près vous
pourriez plaît vsd ça veut dire quoi
vendredi samedi dimanche
oui bah c'est trop tard monsieur nous
sommes mardi
c'est une question qui vous concerne
vous justement prince doit savoir où
vous avez acheté votre couronne voulait
à la boulangerie mais mais la galette
layton sûreté au kof se terminer
monsieur je vous donne rendez-vous c'est
terminé je vous donne rendez vous dans
trois mois pour le divorce
et bien dans le cadre d'autres magazine
littéraire hebdomadaire j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir aujourd'hui un
personnalités de choix un écrivain que
tout le monde connaît puisqu'il s'agit
d'un des phares de la plume française et
du stylo bille sénégalais j'ai noté max
palau
et bien max palau qu'on ne présente plus
et c'est regrettable
chacun a encore en mémoire vos plus
récents succès citons pour mémoire le
soleil sur les ballons de la nuit de
tongs qu'une fois par jour
cela s'appelle le crépuscule également
tout dernièrement je crois un quart
d'heure avant 11h45 oui dont le sous
titre est 11h30
vous venez de publier récemment aux
éditions grassouillette dans les mines
aux ouvrages de correspondance de 350 et
4000 pages dont voici le premier tome et
qui courent donc la période 1936 1980-88
pardon 1983 23 oui puisque 88 alors je
dois dire qu'à la lecture de cet ouvrage
est passionnant vous vous révélez à
témoin privilégié de l'histoire et que
je voudrais d'ailleurs que vous nous
lier à ce propos une très très belle
lettre que vous avez écrite je crois le
8 mai 1945
vous voulez la dir pour les
téléspectateurs oui alors je m'en
souviens très bien ce jour-là j'écrivais
un monsieur tout ya monsieur douillard
chez mon plombier
ce sera donc votre plombier s'appelle
tuya c'est cela mon plombier s'appelle
douillard tuya c'est un nom qu'on trouve
dans le centre de la france il ya
beaucoup de tuya l'enjeu je voulais lit
vous avez vous le dis sans ambages sans
jambes et cher monsieur touya la fuite
que vous avez réparé dans mon lavabo
serre produites et provoquent de graves
désagréments à mon voisin du dessous je
vous serais reconnaissant d'avoir
l'amabilité de bien vouloir la réparer
cordialement vôtre
palau ouais
alors cette lettre est effectivement
très importante car finalement on y
trouve déjà et les principaux thèmes de
23 ans déjà elle thème de la fuite et
fuite en avant je suis ton art guerre
c'est le côté aussi qui symbolise
d'ailleurs le rejet total de la société
est également le thème de l'eau de l'eau
qui coule qui symbolise dit dans
l'éclosion de la vie mais toujours
stoppé par un obstacle qui est le lavabo
bouché
c'est pourquoi ballon je vous pose la
question le lavabo bouché finalement
cette fois c'est le symbole des
contraintes de la société oui c'est
surtout qu'on peut plus laver nos gens
vont venir votre style et si particulier
que je qualifierais disons 2 sera
dépouillé même sec est également
extrêmement florissant verdoyant et j'en
veux pour preuve cette apostrophe
dithyrambique au début de cette lettre
ce cher monsieur touya maximale au jeu
je vous propose ma question pourquoi ce
cher monsieur
parce qu'à l'époque déjà monsieur tugar
ne prenais beaucoup d'argent alors vous
joins également quatre bières des
nouveautés muller par exemple le
signifiant la wagon que vous utilisez
dans son sens le plus éclaté oui parce
que le trio avait pété d'un coup et
également alors ce qui est très
intéressant c'est cette dualité
contenant contenu que l'on retrouve
évidemment un temps plus tard mais alors
tu me lis mais sous la forme d'un
conflit entre les rois et de sa très
nette dans cette très belle lettre que
je crois vous écrivez le 13 mai 1958 si
vous voulez bien la lyre ou
téléspectateurs oui alors je remplissais
un formulaire pour mon dossier maladie
de sécurité sociale je vous le dis sans
ambages sans mandat alors il y avait des
des cases à remplir
non alors j'ai mis ballon je m'appelle
pas nos prénoms max puisque je me
prénomme max est alors finalement c'est
là que se dévoile finalement toute la
dialectique assez subtil de votre pensée
parce que finalement à la question donc
s'agit-il d'un accident vous mettez non
mais à la question suivante causé par un
tiers
vous mettez oui
alors je vous pose la question
finalement max gallo pourquoi ce oui
parce que c'était la grossesse de ma
femme donc contradictions apparentes
dans la monnaie max gallo et pour
reprendre 10 dont la citation d'albert
tranche aux coquillages de la pensée
mais finalement qui révèle fièrement une
très profonde
disons vision du monde extrêmement
cohérente finalement oui puis toute
façon on a été remboursée donc oui alors
gens reviendront finalement au rejet la
société je crois que ça vous a pris très
très tôt dans ma vie ça oui c'est ici si
vous me le permettez une lettre que
j'écrivais lorsque j'étais en vacances à
saint menoux en plein en colonie de
vacances à l'âge de 6 ans et j'écrivais
à matata oui je vous le dis sans ambages
jean bart
cher tata je vais bien je mange bien
mais je joue ne veut pas que je joue au
ballon prisonnier avec lui il me tire
les cheveux il me fait toujours dit
niche vont baisser
maxou n'est c'est cela donc vous ne
signez pas encore à ce moment là pas
long non je signe de mon prénom devrais
je dire de mon surnom car comme de
chacun c'est max ou mais est le
diminutif de max finalement toujours
conflit avec la société la société que
car celui fait par le personnage de jojo
jojo c'est la société
josé la société qui vous tirent les
cheveux pour l'avenir et cheveux
finalement que l'on retrouve dans le
baba bon donc finalement la boucle est
bouclée puisque ce sont les cheveux
qu'il avait bougé n'est pas bon alors on
s'est aperçu en fait que c'était le
bouchon du tube de dentifrice avec de la
ouate qui était dans le tuyau est
toujours votre style si judicieusement
disant bipolaire simplicité extrême et
complicité complexité en extrême du vélo
j'ai ouï plus les fautes d'orthographe
qui sont là pour authentifier la
justesse de mes pensées et la pertinence
de mes propos pertinence d'ailleurs que
l'on retrouvera plus tard dans cette
très belle lettre d'amour que vous
écrivez à l'occasion des grands
événements de mai 1968 si vous voulez
bien le dire alors je voudrais signaler
que c'est la seule lettre d'amour que
j'ai jamais écrite
je vais vous la lire sans ambages sens
en main chère madame
veuillez trouver ci-joint ma photo
couleur dans l'attenté d'une prompte
réponse je vous prie de bien vouloir
agréer l'expression de mes sentiments
distingués
palau
c'est très très émouvant c'est de fougue
sexuelles continuent cependant je dirais
plutôt retenu car j'ai commencé ma
carrière sexuelle et mes premiers ébats
affectif à l'âge de 60 ans eh bien max
palau merci c'est sur ce message
d'espoir
[ __ ] le rôle et son car je crois que
vous avez actuellement du pain sur la
planche vous travaillez à un nouvel
ouvrage wii dont la conception est très
délicate car elle consiste en une
compilation de toutes mes factures d'eau
et de gaz depuis bientôt 30 ans mais
sans doute encore un immense un immense
cri de révolte un filtre max gallo ya de
l'eau dans le gaz